foreign
Pennsylvania hi Nate welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
hey I have a question for you uh kind of
feels like a little bit of a dilemma
that I've been feeling uneasy about
um let me start off I'm in baby step
number one uh just working to save a
thousand dollars right now
um I have thirty two thousand dollars in
debt I have a fifteen thousand dollar uh
car loan that I'm actually trying to
sell this week it's worth 19 private
value
um so hopefully that will work out for
me there my other dilemma here is that
um
I had agreed to this vacation with my
girlfriend that her parents got for us
to go to Key West
and she's like all you got to do is pay
600 my mom paid for bought us the
tickets already and I'm just feeling
really uneasy about that being that I'm
on beans and rice right now and I don't
want to do anything like that I also
don't want to disappoint anybody or hurt
anyone's feelings I'm sorry tell me the
trip again
walk me through that again her parents
they want to give you guys a trip
but not fully yes
exactly so they they announced to you
that they're giving you the gift of a
trip but you have to pay for it
correct for the flight oh for the flight
but when they announced that they were
giving you the trip did they announce
that you were going to pay for the
flight
yes this was something that I was aware
of but now moving forward and seeing
that I've just started the baby steps
I'm like this is something I'm not
comfortable with doing now and I feel
like I'm kind of locked into it did have
the tickets been purchased what do I do
have the tickets been purchased
yes
they purchased them and they're asking
you to re reimburse them
yes and they purchased them after you
agreed to this
yes I did agree to it and then they went
and bought the tickets
yes and now I'm feeling uneasy about it
you bought a ticket
I'm sorry say that again I said that's
tough you've told me to go buy you a
ticket and they went and bought you a
ticket you owe for the ticket you're
going yep yeah sorry if you regret it
but yeah you you you promise these
people you're going to pay them
let me tell you what yeah you're dating
my daughter and you tell me you're going
to do something and then you don't do it
that's a problem I don't want to mess
with that problem Dave yeah
you I mean you gave your word now if
they sprung this on you and then then
expected you to pay for the ticket well
that's them violating a boundary but
they made a proposal they said hey we'll
go on a trip we'll pay for everything
but the airline you pick up your own
Airline and you said I'm in yeah but now
you have you have buyer's remorse is
really what it
trickles down too yeah that's not where
I'm at I suppose yeah I'm sorry Knight
you bought an airline ticket
you need to pay for it you need to go on
the trip and smile
can I ask you one more question are you
going to do that
yeah you can't you can't be a butthead
on the trip because are you gonna go on
the trip and pay them for the ticket
oh I'm gonna have to yeah yeah okay good
all right and be nice
because you signed up for the trip you
signed up father-in-law they did not do
something to you you did something to
you
yeah that's true okay all right now go
ahead I'm sorry your second question is
what
just real quick now being that I'm in
baby step number one and uh getting
ready to sell my car I have 32 000 in
debt and I'm uh looking to get that down
to iOS 15 on it so I'm looking to get
that down to about looks about 17 000
wrestling what are I'm I'm bringing in
45 a year what is what is going to be my
timeline for getting out of debt how
many hours a week are you working now
40 a week okay well you're gonna double
that
get your income up another 30 and you'll
be out of debt in a year the faster the
the more income the more you have thrown
at this debt the faster it's going to
eliminate yeah I mean you're selling
your car for this goal now go give some
of your hours
give some blood to this goal right now
some Blood Sweat and Tears in regards to
getting an A to B car can I go ahead and
get that or yeah
pay cash for it yeah when you sell this
other car you said you're gonna have
transportation right
I should have three or four thousand
dollars I do drive a company vehicle you
have to have you can you use the company
vehicle to go to the grocery store
legally
yes
so why do you have to have another car
I guess it's not completely necessary
not today
no it's it's I mean you you have
transportation you're allowed the
company allows you to drive to church in
the company car or to go to the grocery
store in the company car personal use
reasonable personal use
yep then then drive the company car
and later on when you get out of debt if
you want to pile up a money and get you
a five thousand ten thousand dollar car
to sit in the driveway that's fine but
this car sits in the driveway this is a
very expensive luxury sure is yeah I'm
already throwing it away yeah yeah I I'm
hey all right listen let me tell you the
way my mind works in this okay I don't
want to work 80 hour weeks any longer
than I have to so if I'm you I'm trading
that three or four thousand dollars to
shorten the number of weeks I have to
work my tail end off to get the debt
paid off
okay that's what I'm doing that's how my
mind went when we said do we buy another
car or do we throw this three or four at
it so uh hey I I sense that you're in a
really key moment in your life that a
whole bunch of things are changing for
you at once in a good way there's a lot
of growing up going on there's a lot of
stepping into responsibility going on uh
you're asking ethical questions lots of
good things happening with you right now
I want you to continue to lean into all
of this and don't pull back from it
because it you may feel the fire a
little bit on some of this time this
time of transformation for you you may
feel some heat at some point lean into
the heat don't back up from it because I
think God's got some really cool things
for you coming Nate I love that don't
you I believe it there's a whole bunch
of different points in that story yeah
you can tell that his priorities his
priorities are shifting he's starting to
put a lot more thought into the
decisions that he's making I think he's
about to buy her a ring hey hey just
make sure she's on board with the plan
I'm but I'm thinking I think I think and
I think that made him get real serious
about ethics not only with her parents
but everybody get real serious about
getting this mess cleaned up that'll put
the house on the market I'm I'm so
serious I'm gonna call Dave and Jade and
let them beat me up if I have to let's
go get it done you know yeah and that
that was he's in a cool place I like
this guy good for him